fabien roussel nous rejoignent des
députés pcf du nord secrétaire nationale
du parti communiste français merci
monsieur roussel merci d'être avec nous
je voudrais rebondir avec vous sur les
propos de didier poulain alain seban qui
parle de mea culpa de la classe
politique française
est ce que vous êtes d'accord écoutez
excusez-moi j'ai pris l'émission compte
donc j'ai pas écouter tout ce qu'a dit
votre interlocuteur avant une chose est
sûre en tout cas c'est que personne ne
pourra dire nous ne savions pas ce qui
est en train de se passer dans ce pays
notre pays est frappé là en quelques
jours coup sur coup par des actes des
actes de terroristes islamiques et donc
c'est particulièrement grave
il ne faut pas nier cette réalité elle
existe et donc effectivement tout doit
être mis en oeuvre pour empêcher ces
islamistes de da tenté à la vie de nos
concitoyens
ce soit des enseignants que ce soit là
des hommes d'église
il y a aujourd'hui une volonté de nuire
un autre pays à la république et nous
devons pour cela faire front être unis
le plus possible et éviter de tomber
dans la division du pays de tomber dans
la guerre de religion que les islamistes
veulent provoquer chez nous alors
monsieur roussel pourquoi la france est
très sportive
écoutez la france est prise pour cible
comme d'autres pays mais
particulièrement nous parce que nous
avons une une
une histoire au sein de notre république
lié à notre manière de faire vivre la
laïcité le respect de chacun de croire
ou de ne pas croire nous avons mis en
oeuvre en 1905 la loi sur la laïcité la
séparation des églises et de l'état
c'est une spécificité de la france et il
ya aussi une spécificité dans notre pays
c'est le droit au blasphème le droit de
pouvoir caricaturer une liberté
d'expression pleine et entière et ce
droit là nous voulons le défendre
l'assumé pleinement
et il ne s'agit pas de céder sur ce
point là et donc ça fait l'objet
d'attentats horribles contre les
journalistes et ceux de charlie hebdo
notamment et aujourd'hui c'est au nom
aussi de cela qu il y a eu l'attentât
contre l'enseignant samuel paty et donc
parce que notre pays défend cette
liberté d'expression pleine et entière
et bien notre pays est aujourd'hui
attaquée mais nous ne devons pas céder
surtout pas à ces attaques et donc nous
devons résister tous ensemble
monsieur roussel reprend les mots d'eric
ciotti nous sommes en guerre
la france est en guerre contre qui
la france est aujourd'hui attaquée par
des hommes qui au nom qui disent que au
nom de leur religion s'en prendraient à
notre pays
c'est effectivement comme s'était dit
avant ceux qui théorisent le choc des
civilisations qui s'en prennent à notre
pays un autre république à nos valeurs
alors quelle est la réponse la meilleure
réponse à apporter
il ya la réponse de la fermeté et de la
justice a apporté tout de suite et je
souhaite d'ailleurs je voudrais saluer
les forces de l'ordre qui aujourd'hui
sont face à haas et à ces drames sont
mobilisés et donc nous avons besoin
d'apporter une réponse de fermeté mais
nous devons aussi donc prendre
conscience que dans notre pays des
français sont aujourd'hui en train de
tomber dans une forme dans un islamisme
qui veut imposer sa loi et sur notre sol
et ce sont des français qui bien souvent
sont à l'origine de ces attaques
et donc nous devons prendre conscience
ça veut dire qu'il ya aussi un travail à
faire sur du long terme
nous devons nous attaquer aussi au
terreau sur lequel donc le terrorisme
peut prendre ses racines il est multiple
donc nous devons nous attaquer bien sûr
à aux réseaux salafistes à ce qui arrive
à infiltrer
aujourd'hui notre pays faut s'attaquer
aux sources de financement de ces
réseaux nous devons comme je les dis
lors des dernières questions d'actualité
peut-être interrogé aussi les relation
que la france entretient avec certains
de ces pays dont on sait qu'ils
financent des réseaux jihadistes et que
à qui nous nous vendons largement des
armes avec qui nous avons des
conventions fiscales parfois très
avantageuse et donc il serait bon aussi
que nous revoyons les relations que nous
ayons avec ces pays en tout cas il est
clair qu'il y a besoin de prendre
conscience de ce qui se passe dans notre
pays pour avec fermeté avec justice nous
arrivions à empêcher ces attaques mais
aussi à rester unie à rester unis
puisque ce sera la meilleure force est
la meilleure réponse à apporter à notre
pays c'est que les citoyens français
quelles que soient leurs opinions
politiques et leurs religions doivent
rester unis merci beaucoup à fabien ont
fait